ah the impossible task of ranking the
Joker's why because whether you first
saw him in a comic the Animated Series
played the Arkham games or watched him
live-action we all grew up kind of
loving different versions let's start
with Cesar Romero he was the Joker in
the campy 1960s Batman starring Adam
West and while a little more
family-friendly he said a precedent for
portraying the Joker on screen yeah he
refused to shave his mustache so they're
just kind of makeup smeared over his
face
but we've all seen this image the one
with the creepy smile that will be
forever ingrained into my brain and
importantly he has a good laugh okay
let's go all the way to 1989 when Jack
Nicholson brought the Joker to life in
the Tim Burton directed version the
addition of the prosthetics make his
smile really unsettling and this is a
more sadistic version of the Joker which
we're really into and we kind of see
from this point forward every dance with
the devil in the pale light but I do
have to say I'm really aware that I'm
watching Jack Nicholson on-screen I
didn't really I don't get lost in the
character like I do with say Heath
Ledger now I'm always smiling now I'm
not going full live-action here because
I can't talk about the Joker without
bringing up Mark Hamill takes one bad
day he's voiced the Joker for decades
meaning at this point generations of
kids have stopped in their tracks to the
sounds of Hamill's creepy cackle so I'm
not even knowing that it's in if you've
watched the animated series or played
the Rocksteady Arkham games you've
definitely heard it yeah when I think of
the most iconic Joker moments I've seen
across the board my mind goes to places
one when I played the Arkham series I
love that Joker put him on street in
real life and then of course when I was
sitting in stores celebration just a
month ago Mark Hamill read an excerpt
from The Killing Joke and the room just
died everyone died memories can be filed
through both of little Bruce
like children I suppose it's Heath
Ledger's posthumous role in the Dark
Knight that ranks number one like I said
before I get really lost in this
character and it's not just because he's
covered up in clown makeup it was
everything from the voice to the
mannerisms that make Heath Ledger become
the Joker I don't think any complaints
can really be about his performance I
think people can complain about the
character qualities that were changed
for the movie but hey if Christopher
Nolan wanted a dark gritty version of
the Joker there's no denying that Heath
Ledger did exactly that because it's all
part of the plan okay who is your
favorite Joker of all time and why you
can comment below or tweet me opinions
can't be wrong
and of course after seeing Suicide Squad
this weekend let me know where Jared
Leto fits in your ranking
you